hier ist sie die Show mit Preisen
das Weihnachtsgewinnspiel von Kingstone
bei uns hat sich ja über das Jahr die
ein oder andere CD oder DVD angesammelt
hier zum Beispiel ich und ich Live CD
und DVD und die wollen wir jetzt unter
die Leute bringen und das geht ganz
einfach auf unseren Kanal Seite gibt es
ja diese
advents-weihnachtsstrümpfe und ab dem 1
dezember wird jeden Tag hier quasi ein
Zettelchen aus dem Strumpf geholt aber
dann wieder verpackt das ist nämlich der
Haken das heißt ihr müsst euch diese
Zahl notieren die jeden jeweils neben
dem jeweiligen Datum steht und heute zum
Beispiel ist die Lösung einfach diese
Zahl die neben der eins steht so das
kann aber ganz anders werden das kann
zum Beispiel am
sagen wir mal am 23 Dezember kann es
sein dass wir fragen nach der Zahl die
neben dem dritten und dem 15 Dezember
gestanden hat je nachdem also jeden Tag
auf die Kanalseite gucken da steht dann
was wir suchen auch und im aktuellen
Video steht immer in einer Anmerkung
welche Zahlen wir suchen und das ganze
dann melden an Klicks zum at gmail.com
und dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr
schief gehen ähm ich drück die da ach ja
und am 24 Dezember da gibt es den
Hauptpreis der nicht ganz scheiße ist
also seid gespannt ich drück die Daumen
und dann frohes gewinnen und mitspielen